últimas oportunidades para los
candidatos franceses pero un primer y
único mitin para emanuel manjón en no
tener en las afueras de parís la
estrategia del presidente saliente para
convencer a los indecisos sigue siendo
la defensa de su balance
si estoy comprometido con el objetivo
del pleno empleo
[Aplausos]
porque gracias a todo lo que hemos hecho
juntos durante estos cinco años por
primera vez desde mediados de los años
setenta
nuestro país puede decir que en los
próximos cinco años alcanzará el pleno
empleo si es posible
del lado de la izquierda también hubo
mítines el candidato del nuevo partido
anticapitalista film habló frente a un
público de la capital cuando el
candidato del partido comunista fabián
hoss él estaba más al sur cerca de lyon
su objetivo distinguirse de los demás
prometiendo atacar a la delincuencia de
cuello blanco no
hablemos ataque a la nunca han querido
abordar el fraude y la evasión fiscal
onu ue pues para nosotros sí lo digo hoy
y a estas alturas de la campaña será una
prioridad aumentar el presupuesto del
estado reforzar nuestros servicios
públicos aumentar los salarios y las
pensiones
a otra ciudad recibiendo un candidato
marsella donde erick se visitó el
mercadillo ilegal
vean hay que limpiar esto físicamente
limpiar a la gente que está haciendo
todos estos tráficos enviarlos de vuelta
a su lugar de origen porque en su
mayoría son ilegales de cualquier
nacionalidad que sean hay que enviarlos
de vuelta a casa y no dejarlos aquí por
más tiempo
mañana otros cinco candidatos ofrecerán
mítines más traición ipic este año del
winter y acto en parís sonic relación en
toulouse y son las salen clausurando un
fin de semana de última oportunidad
antes de la votación del 10 de abril